a stunning new poll
shows Trump support among Republicans
collapsing to Historic lows you have to
see this it doesn't bode well for prompt
and it does start to point to will this
guy even make it to the first Republican
primaries USA Today reports
via Yahoo news Trump in trouble
Republican support for his 2024 bid
Falls amid political and legal setbacks
this is a USA Today Suffolk University
poll and it finds that by a two to one
margin
Republican and republican-leaning voters
say they want Trump's policies but they
want someone other than Trump to be the
nominee 31 of Republicans want Trump to
run
61 of Republicans believe it should be a
different Republican nominee mostly to
continue Trump's policies which is funny
because it's like what policies he did
nothing other than putting in place some
confused tariffs uh they have a name in
mind rights uh USA Today two-thirds of
Republicans and those inclined to vote
Republican want
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis to run for
president by double digits 56 to 33 they
prefer DeSantis over Trump
these are stunning numbers I know people
will write to me and say David they're
only calling landlines no
uh Suffolk USA Today uses cell phones as
well well but David think about who
would even answer a phone call from a
pollster
okay yes a lot of people don't answer
their phone but I don't know that the
people who answer are disproportionately
likely to be DeSantis supporters I mean
it seems that this is a fair poll that
was done as correctly as any poll would
be done so this is a red flag for Donald
Trump and the question continues to be
can Trump make it to the primaries or is
support going to Crater to such a degree
that he's going to bail to avoid a
further humiliation and cite health
reasons or some other thing that he
wants to do we don't know the answer
it's very early but the early numbers
aren't looking good we'll talk more
about uh campaign events which are
starting to be put on the calendar
sometime soon we're going to take a
quick break all the clips I played for
you today will be on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman show and of
course they will all be on our YouTube
channel
subscribe on YouTube okay
three I just got the November numbers
3.4 million people in November watched
our Clips but aren't subscribed if we
can get just a third of those 3.4
million people overnight we get to 2
million YouTube subscribers make it
happen my friends
huge numbers of people report that CBD
has a calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue CBD can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects the thing
to remember about CBD is that finding
the right dose is important and feels
even has experts on call to help you
with that over the phone if you need a
dose of Chill on the go you've got the
feels CBD infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership CBD
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below